the answer to the question is 20
different professionals
can work on one single architectural
project
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here thank you so much for
joining me on this channel we talk about
architecture and technology
so if that's something that interests
you make sure you smash that subscribe
button
and let's get on with today's video
today we're talking about
how many professionals it takes to
design
one single home now we're going to be
talking about a very complex home here
potentially a very luxury
residential home this isn't your
standard run-of-the-mill home
you don't need this many consultants for
something that's a little bit easier
however if you do have a very complex
home or a very complex project
more than likely most if not all of
these people
will be involved throughout the project
in some way shape or form so most of the
time the project starts through the
architect which is your first consultant
the architect is the one that draws up
the plans navigates the mind field that
is the construction industry
and helps you get your project off the
ground the second consultant that we
engage
straight off the bat is a land surveyor
they go out to your site
measure up the site in full 3d usually
so we know exactly where all the levels
and how the land works
after the land surveyor comes the
geotechnical consultant the geotechnical
consultant will go out on site
drill a couple boreholes and test the
ground
they will come out and tell you what
soil type is
active on that piece of land it is very
important that we understand the soil
type so the engineers
can design around this soil type so for
example if you come back with a class
p site straight away you know that's a
problem site it's going to be reactive
the earth's going to move and shift so
the engineers have to design accordingly
this is a critical step even though it
seems so insignificant
as we continue designing usually we
finish one or two sketch designs before
we start engaging the heavier
consultants
these other consultants start coming
into the project a little bit later on
but they do definitely come in in waves
if it is a complex project and a complex
home that has a minefield of planning
services to get around
potentially not necessarily you'll be
engaging a planning consultant to help
get you through all those planning
conditions that might make this house
otherwise impossible
and for one reason or another the house
is actually an extension
to a heritage home well then not many
architects
specialize in heritage so it is always
recommended that a heritage consultant
be brought on board
when any heritage home is involved
so straight away before we've even
started documentation
we have so many consultants to list so
once we start getting into the
construction drawing side of things
this is where even more consultants come
on board this is where
a predominant amount of the engineers
come on board
so the engineers usually come on board
in order we have your structural
engineer who deals with all
your structural members of the house
your roof trusses your steel columns
your footings for example
second we have your hydraulic engineer
the hydraulic engineer usually deals
with all the plumbing fixtures on the
property thirdly we have a mechanical
engineer
contrary to popular belief the
mechanical engineer doesn't just work on
cars
that isn't their job role a mechanical
engineer works on air conditioning and
air conditioning spaces
typically speaking they do a lot more
than just air conditioning but in a
house they predominantly focus on the
air conditioning and ventilation systems
fourth we have a civil engineer imagine
if your site was
cut into the side of a cliff you want to
make sure
that cliff isn't just going to fall away
one day so the civil engineers job
is to be able to ensure all the grades
are correct the site's going to be able
to hold up
that the drainage works properly and
there's going to be no movement
in that ground next we might have our
acoustic engineers and our fire
engineers
so if you want to make sure that your
house is acoustically perfect
and that you aren't having noise
transfer between one slab and another or
one room and another
for whatever reason say you have a
youtube studio
and you're doing phenomenally well that
you want that room to be perfect
well then an acoustic engineer has to
come on board and help with this process
the fire engineer on the other hand
deals with well everything fire related
any sprinkler systems that you might
need any pumps and tanks you might need
how the firefighters are actually going
to be able to come to your property
and tackle a fire if there is one
neither of these consultants are
required on every job but they are an
optional extra
now that's about it from the engineers
and this is usually where we also engage
our national construction code
consultant or our ncc consultant for
short
because the ncc is a couple thousand
pages long it is specifically
somebody's job to know exactly what is
going on in that document and to guide
everybody in every single different
profession
on that book so the ncc consultant will
guide us as architects we'll guide the
engineers we'll guide almost everybody
to be able to assist and make sure it
complies with the national construction
code in australia
now i'm sure that around the world we
all have different standards or
different terms for this
but there is more than likely going to
be an ncc consultant
in your area that's able to help with
this project
now in australia another consultant that
you won't be able to get a building
permit without
is an energy efficiency consultant the
energy efficiency consultant's role
is to take all the information from all
the other consultants
and consolidate that into an energy
report how much
energy is that house theoretically using
and
how many stars does it achieve in a
green star rating
so for example coming up in western
australia very shortly depending on when
you're watching this video
all new homes must comply with six star
energy efficiency
so that usually means double glazed
windows no penetrations in the ceiling
or minimal at least and many other
elements that
usually didn't have to be accommodated
to so this is our way of trying to
reduce the global impact of energy
consumption
and making these houses more solar
passive and self-sustainable in my
personal opinion as
difficult as this is to design in some
climates and as
unachievable as it is in others it is
definitely a good move forward for the
architecture industry
now there's so many consultants i'm
starting to run out of breath but if you
had a multi-level luxury home that you
had to run up and down the stairs all
day every day
you'd probably start running out of
breath too so most of the time we place
a lift
into these designs which means a lift
consultant must be brought onto the
project and if you're going to be
spending that money
on a lift it means you're also going to
be spending some money on interior
design
that means we're more than likely going
to bring in an interior architect to
help with that element
but we can't forget about the outside
the outside requires
some very detailed design and it
requires an expert that knows what
they're talking about
so a landscape architect is usually
brought in to help make
every garden absolutely perfect but what
if there's a tree
right in the middle of the property that
is potentially causing a threat or
another
tree that is dying but is also
potentially a heritage listed tree
what happens in these situations well
then we can also bring in an arborist
now for a long time i didn't know what
an arborist was but basically the
easiest definition of an arborist
is a tree surgeon they'll come in
inspect the tree make sure it is alive
and healthy and advise
how it can be maintained or cut down in
the appropriate circumstances
so an arborist and a landscaper will
potentially be working on this job as
well
and finally if you're building this
beautiful dream home and spending
all this money on consultants you don't
want to be screwed
by the builder with a hefty price so
most of the time
with projects that are large and very
significant
in monetary value we bring in a quantity
surveyor
the quantity surveyor's role is
basically to analyze every element of
that project
and be able to quantify how much things
are worth so when a builder comes in
with a quote and says this house is
going to cost 10 million dollars
the quantity surveyor has facts and
figures to back up this
and check every single element so
quantity surveyors fee
is worth their weight in gold especially
on larger projects
now just so i haven't missed any and you
guys don't go commenting down david that
was only 19.
quick recap for you all one architect
two
geotechnical three structural four
electrical
five hydraulic six ncc consultant seven
surveyor
eight mechanical nine acoustic ten fire
eleven energy efficiency 12 lift
consultant
13 landscape architect 14 interior
architect
15 access consultant i did miss one
16 arborist 17 quantity surveyor 18
planning consultant 19 civil engineer
and 20 heritage consultant
the one i missed is the access
consultant and the reason i missed this
one is because the access consultant
is very rare and the access consultant
is the one that is usually
brought on for larger commercial
projects not so much residential homes
however if you do have some sort of
disability or any
sort of access requirements in that home
the access consultant is able to provide
full documentation on how this home can
be utilized to the best of your
abilities
and that is all the consultants listed
as they usually appear in a project
there are many many many more
consultants that can be
engaged in an architectural project
however these are just
some of the consultants i deal with on a
day-to-day basis
it is very rare that all of these
consultants will be engaged on one
single project
but at least 65 to 75 of these
consultants
will be engaged on these larger projects
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
i hope you got a lot of information out
of it i know there was a lot of
information
but if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
and because this video forms one of my
28 videos
in 28 days for february of 2021
usually it would be see you next monday
however because it is february
i will see you tomorrow